evidence in this case will
clearly show
leave you absolutely no doubt
that mr holder
killed
hernias astradam
and injured kerry lincoln and sherman
williams
there'd be no doubt about that
you're going to hear and see evidence
that he
had plenty of opportunity
to think about what he was going to do
before he did it
and did
and i made that point because
we charged not just murder
but premeditated and deliberately
the difference between premeditated and
deliberate murder and murder will be
argued during at the end of the case
march 31st
2019
at about 3 20
in the afternoon there was an explosion
of violence
at that place and at that time
the world lost
hermes joseph askadam
better known to the world isn't it
hustle
mr ascadon was a father he was a son he
was a brother
he was a successful artist
an entrepreneur
he was beloved in his neighborhood
he was respected
he was just 33 years old there was a
conversation between mr holder and mr
astradam
minutes before
mr
holder shot and killed mr aston
and you will hear from at least two
different witnesses
that that conversation has something to
do
with smitching
now i know you're all familiar with the
word snitch and the concept of snitching
but you may not be familiar with how
volatile that subject is within gang
life
if someone is considered if a gang
member is considered snitch
it's a whole lot different from
being considered a snitch
by your little brother or your little
sister
there are a lot of
there's a range of consequences for
people to snitch
but no gang member wants to be
considered a snitch it is highly
offensive to any gang member to even
be suggested that he
but he was there when the shooting
happened
and
what mr lathan is able to tell you is
that he's just sitting there leaning
back against the car
when he hears your through and he looks
over and sees his muzzle flash
he walks along the sidewalk in front of
the businesses until he gets to
the two cars where these gentlemen are
and
no sooner than he walks between the cars
he pulls out not one but two guns
and he starts shooting
he starts shooting in this very tight
confined space where there are four
people
and he strikes three of the four people
nitsy hustle struck almost immediately
and
you'll hear about one of his injuries
transected his spine
severed his spinal cord and when you see
him drop he almost drops like head
weight and he never he's never able to
move again